We're told that as part of an
experiment about train speed,
4 different train conductors
measured the distance that
they covered over a certain
amount of time
during a recent journey.
So these are the 4 trains.
This is how long it took them
to go this many miles.
However, they all use different
time intervals.
Yeah, you see this guy, he
did it over half an hour.
This guy did it over 2 hours.
And they're having a difficult
time comparing their data.
According to the data provided,
were all 4 trains
moving at the same speed
during the experiment?
So we just have to figure out
what was the speed of all of
these 4 trains based on
how far they went in
this amount of time.
And just to remind us, you might
already know this, but
you know that distance is equal
to rate times time.
Or if you were to divide both
sides of this equation by
time, I could do that.
If you divide both sides by
time, the times cancel out and
you get rate is equal to
distance divided by time.
Rate is the same thing as speed,
and it makes sense that
it's distance divided by time.
You've heard miles per hour
or meter per second or
kilometers per hour.
Rate speed is distance
divided by time.
So we can just use this.
We can just divide the distance
by the time for each
of these trains and figure
out what their speed was.
So let's do that.
So let's write their speeds.
I'll make another column for
their speed right here.
So what's this first guy?
He went 27.5 miles
in 0.5 hours.
So once again, let's divide the
distance for this train 1.
He went 27.5 miles in 0.5.
So if you divide something by
0.5, this is the same thing as
27.5 times 2.
Let me do it this
way, times 2.
What's 27.5 times 2?
It is 55, and it is
miles per hour.
So his speed is 55
Now, this guy, this is pretty
straightforward.
He went 55 miles in
exactly 1 hour.
The distance divided
by time is 55.
So this guy's pretty
straightforward.
He's also 55.
And you can put it
in the formula.
55 is the distance.
The time is 1 hour.
55 over 1.
55 miles per hour.
Now this guy went 82-1/2
miles in 1-1/2 hours.
Let's see what that is.
So he went 82-1/2 miles
in 1.5 hours.
So let's figure out
what this is.
And I'll have to do a little bit
of decimal long division
to do this.
So we have 1.5 goes into 82.5.
Let's multiply both of these
numbers by 10, essentially
shift their decimals one
over, so shift that
decimal over here.
So it becomes 15 goes into
825 how many times?
So 15 doesn't go
into 8 at all.
It goes into 82 five times.
5 times 5 is 25, carry the 2.
5 times 1 is 5, plus 2 is 70.
Subtract 75.
82 minus 75 is just
a 7, right?
And then you bring
down this 5.
15 goes into 75 five
times exactly.
5 times 15 is 75.
Subtract, no remainder.
So 82.5 miles in an hour
and a half is also
55 miles per hour.
And then finally, if you do 110
miles 2 hours, 110 divided
by 2 is 55.
So they did indeed all go, or
they all did move at the same
speed during the experiment.